esta es radio canadá internacional
bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
café o el castor cibernético una emisión
producida por la sección en español del
difusor público radio canadá
internacional difundimos en directo cada
viernes a las dos y cuarto por internet
esta emisión también se encuentra
disponible en nuestro sitio r cine de
puntos
les invitamos a contactarnos con sus
comentarios y críticas nuestro correo
electrónico amlat
heresi net punto sea y si prefiere
escribirnos una carta de verdad nuestro
correo regular es radio canadá
internacional apartado postal 6000
montreal canadá el código postal h 13 3
a 8 tengo un problema con la carta de
verdad cuál gmail también es de verdad
pues virtual así lo imprime y estará
físicamente den en tu pantalla se
encuentra claro pero es virtual
convengamos mismo
ya pueden ver entonces aquí las las
huestes están dispuestas a mí yo no oí
con ustedes llorando gimeno pablo gómez
barrios y barrios así así paloma
martínez como están muy bien que les
habla rojo valencia en la versión radio
o audio o la antigua versión de este
programa disponible nuestro sitio y eres
en el punto sea escucharemos hoy a uno
de los grupos canadienses nominados a
los premios y uno de música canadiense
arcade fire con dos temas mandadme mes
de mayo del álbum de saberes lanzado en
2010 y guardan de su más reciente álbum
everything out todo a obra lanzado en
julio del año pasado también
escucharemos una canción en francés y
español un hombre y un hombre al mar y
una mala men interpretado por el
canadiense steve y shock en su segundo
álbum dedicado esto ya de asia 2000 2003
así que es bastante antiguo 2003
así que totalmente en un lugar que se va
a bagan es aquí en montreal así que 2003
y el siglo pasado casi cuando nació mi
hijo ya y muy bien ya empezamos con las
noticias que les han sorprendido esta
semana a ver qué es lo que tienen en la
miel el nuevo formato de currículum que
se usa en eeuu como heces y
particularmente el on mars
usó un curriculum mostró que puede
después de solamente aproximadamente 12
15 años de empresa mandó
el cohete más grande creado en la
historia con un auto dentro si usted
dice
ese nombre que de unos años treinta y
cuarenta sílaba los autos que los
jóvenes los les daban más fuerza para
correr las carnaciones un gallo también
sus tres años
él tiene un problema auditivo y la
pronunciación que acaba de mostrar este
hombre que todo se puede con fondos
privados en montó su empresa desde casi
cero digamos y ahora tiene bueno la
posibilidad de tener contratos hiper
multimillonarios con
los gobiernos de todo el mundo para
mandar misiones a marte a mar por
ejemplo
amarme se acerca el día del romantic
cuando dijiste amarte me imaginé amado
no pero he amado realmente es una manera
muy especial de mostrar las capacidades
y de dejar en puerta a la abierta de
todos los contratos que se vienen para
para estas nuevas campañas
interplanetarias y lo he hecho yo creo
que los más
es increíble en ese sentido algo que
hemos hecho es ayudar a nuestros amigos
[Música]
fue fue el más que el que hizo está un
concurso para aquellas personas que
quieren ir a marte había un chico y él
dijo que él en el primer viaje no iba
porque quería supervisar las cosas
asegurarse que llegaban vivos y que no
rostizados y lo interesante es que lo
que me llama a mí también la atención no
esta semana está relacionado con la
misma noticia de la que habla a leonardo
y es la diferencia del costo entre lo
que le costaba a la nasa enviar a un
transbordador al espacio y lo que le
costó a los mosca la industria privada
finalmente enviar a su cohete y el hecho
de que el cohete hay un montón de partes
del cohete que son reutilizables que
vuelven que se estacionan solas que
tienen digamos la clave y recuperan
partes también salió exacto que que eso
también baja muchísimo el costo de la
carrera espacial y entonces la pregunta
que me hago yo es por qué la industria
privada puede reducir costos y enviar
cohetes de esa forma
y los fondos públicos estadounidenses no
sean capaces de hacer lo mismo ya sea
porque hay un solo jefe en la compañía y
no está activa el público donde hay
yo me pregunte si estaban si eran de la
misma calidad los cohetes
mandando gente todavía sólo mandó un
coche
todavía no manda gente pero ya va a
llegar o sea lo que hizo la nasa en
cuanto 60 70 años se lo hizo un 15
tomar en cuenta el crash 3 exponencial
de la tecnología
obviamente no no no hombre no estoy
hablando en detrimento de la nasa ni a
favor de lo más sino que realmente el
hecho me parece llamó sobresaliente
desde el punto de vista tecnológico y
que él haya logrado ese financiamiento y
que haya logrado poner eso en orbyt o
sea es difícil desde el punto de vista
yo mañana quiero abrir una empresa
cualquiera sea y tiene un montón de
obstáculos y los tuvo y sin embargo fue
organizándose de manera tal para poder
digamos esquivar los escollos y está en
este momento en un punto de poder
importantísimo
o sea demostró que puede mandar por
la nasa podría mandar gente pero no
podía mandar peso entonces si éste está
mandando un auto adentro o sea está
mandando está demostrando que se puede
mandar para mandar mucho más peso cuando
uno piensa en misiones en marte hay que
abastecer a esas misiones en marte bueno
acá tenés el producto y para mandar los
abastecimientos a marte con menos peso
mucho menos pesos
el marciano este astronauta terrestre
terrícola es olvidado en el planeta
marte que tiene que dedicarse cultivar
papas de manera muy para terminar si es
porque la idea de mandar un carro de
hecho se preguntan si no es basura
espacial eso o sea de enviar un tesla en
el espacio y bueno sea como golpe
publicitario pues para test ley para él
son más que fantástico pedro [ __ ] el que
iguales
es comparar el botón
al botón nuclear d yo creo que es los
erráticos yo creo que es un excelente
digamos el currículum vítae están
mostrando qué es lo que se puede hacer
me está diciendo erakat acá estoy acá
está esta empresa a su disposición
podemos mandar hasta autos hola
el desechos desechos muchos menos de los
que había con la nasa que quedan
espacios porque evidentemente porque se
recuperan como decíamos exacto y lo que
me interesó esta semana es también tiene
que ver con tecnología con facebook
porque facebook está proponiendo parece
que se parece esta semana no está en
pruebas de un nuevo botón pero el botón
no es el botón me gusta no ni es nuclear
ni ese no me gusta como porque tenemos
el botón me gusta y no es un no me gusta
pero es un botón en el que puedes
expresar de alguna manera algo que te
desagrada pero o que no estás de acuerdo
con el punto de vista de alguien o de
'la o de una noticia como tal entonces
están creando como como hicieron para él
me gusta que tiene varias como opciones
pensiones de felicidad el corazón la
flor en en la época primavera
acto lo mismo pero para el botón que es
que diría que el que podría reportar
contenidos que no son pertinentes para
un público tal o que puedes decir esta
persona está ofendiendo a hoy a este
grupo social entre comillas entonces me
parece interesante que están haciendo
una opción para que uno exprese también
cuando no está de acuerdo cuando uno
quiere reportar algo en particular con
igual se podía las funciones no pero no
con un botón pero si lo podía mandar un
reporte a través no podía denunciar
especificó estar incluido entre los de
los botoncitos aquí tengo un comentario
bueno de danielle camporini está en
línea en este momento en línea bueno no
está escucha viendo allá desde buenos
aires y él dice vamos a contaminar marte
y esa era una de las era justamente en
los comentarios que se hacía sí
hay que tener mucho cuidado con lo que
enviamos en el espacio porque si se
trata de buscar
vida extraterrestre que no nos vayamos a
encontrar con las mismas bacterias que
tenemos acá entonces si dejamos la
basura por ahí dando vueltas
lo que destacó esta semana es justamente
este no sé si es algo muy personal pero
este está este clima como que como de
paz que hay sobre todo debido a los
juegos el lincoln del norte en que en
que la calabaza de la casa blanca está
más tranquila dejó de tuitear y ahí como
que hay menos el botón los botones
nucleares están más si los alejaron 10
sentimientos pero me gustó ver a los dos
abanderados del equipo de corea de la
corea unida llevando la bandera juntos
les costó un poco de trabajo porque
había mucho viento entonces estaba
soplando la base del otro lado entonces
pero me gustó verlos porque me parece
que es importante largo y creo que
porque todos podríamos hacer un esfuerzo
y lo que realiza lo que más destacable
es que ellos los coreanos pueden hablar
entre ellos los problemas sin que
alguien venga a decir que alguien claro
y por eso la declaración de mike pence
el vicepresidente
korea a estas tres olímpicos para decir
de que no va a dejar que corea del norte
acapara la atención en los juegos es
decir que bueno por lo menos hay por lo
menos los coreanos del sur saben que
mientras hay juegos y atletas de corea
del norte ya hay menos chances de que
hayan cohetes así que aumentó como una
pequeña tribuna para lucha y menos menos
mensajes en twitter entonces es lo que
yo destacó esta semana si me llama la
atención también no sé si se ponga este
país si el gesto el tanguero que
apareció una cámara que tenía calor que
estaba sudando pero seguro ser militante
no creo que pueda pasearse y pavonearse
a torso desnudo qué frío igualito
pero a siete grados bajo cero con
sensación térmica
yo lo encuentro muy valiente el tanguero
sí con ella buena noticia para montreal
para esta semana es que el domingo
vuelve a él 20 centímetros más de nivel
y la municipalidad ya dijo que no tienen
más espacio para poner nieve pero hoy
anunciaron que había y anunciaron que
habían encontrado a haber llegado a un
acuerdo con el gobierno provincial para
que les asignarán espacios extras para
ir a llevar la nieve y los juegos
olímpicos de pyonyang
grada ya ha enviado 225 atletas y
américa tiene su total ha enviado 33
atletas hay cuatro de méxico el que más
envía es chile con siete
brasil méxico ecuador manda uno una
persona y amanda 2
no es un es un noruego y dos europeos
del norte que tomaron la ciudad
boliviana iván es que hablan guapa
así que en toda la historia del juegos
olímpicos esto no sabía de invierno
américa latina nunca ganó una sola
medalla
claro bueno yo vi que uno de los
mexicanos que baile contaba pablo antes
de entrar al estudio es un patinador
artístico muy bueno y tiene una tiene
una una rutina con una canción de juan
gabriel y simat y canción
creo
[Música]
[Risas]
otros dos comentarios en este caso
daniel campos y me dice algunos
personajes que sería bueno enviar sin
ticket de regreso no alcanzarían los
aviones
tenemos que buscar un cohete mucho más
grande y javier garay nos dice saludos
hasta montreal desde guadalajara méxico
siempre que había y acompañándonos
entonces un abrazo grande para irme al
pie del cañón y avisé no si ustedes
están siguiendo a los juegos olímpicos
de invierno si están siguiendo a sus
atletas nacionales a ver cuáles se
porque hay un fervor argentino
si hay argentinos cuando vengan nos van
6 argentinos
en tanto en mendoza como tirando más
hacia el sur en bariloche hay centros de
esquí donde se puede entrenar digamos
aunque no durante todo el año pero tiene
más posibilidades que los que viven en
el que cualquier otro país
es lógico son australes bien vamos ahora
voy a dar una primera vuelta a las
cartas que tenemos y entonces qué tal si
empezamos contigo para un amigo
es un mensaje que nos llega de javier
gonzález nungaray justamente dice sobre
el tema batalla de generaciones en la
armada canadiense triunfan los jóvenes y
el wifi o el wifi de acuerdo a la
investigación que realizó la marina
canadiense se establece que las nuevas
generaciones es decir los jóvenes
canadienses le hacían el feo a
reclutarse en la marina por el simple
hecho de no actualizarse
tecnológicamente instalación del wifi en
sus buques bueno hay que ajustarse a la
modernidad tecnológica dice javier
gonzález nungaray saludos cordiales y
76-73 rufo valència espero que te hayas
te la hayas pasado bien en navidad y el
año nuevo silala espacio muy bien eficaz
y creo que fue ese año pasado y estamos
en casi medio febrero
y allí realidad
y bien con respecto a la prostitución
tiene cara juvenil en la web con erótica
dice personalmente creo que se deberían
aprobar leyes que regularicen la
prostitución para qué
ellas puedan ejercer con todos sus
derechos como cualquier trabajador
normal entonces pues comentario de con
eróticas tengo aquí comentarios sobre
canadá y su plan de inmigración 2018
iván jesús aquino bájese dice me
gustaría vivir a canadá con mis dos
hijas y mi esposa que necesito hacer
bueno ir a los sitios de inmigración
canadá y están todos los datos y yo te
recomiendo iván que si bien es que no
vengas en invierno en verano para que
matarte por lo menos para recuperar el
invierno esa niña
tengo aquí otro mensaje de bruno
aumentan estaciones de recarga para
autos eléctricos en nueva brunswick sin
duda los vehículos eléctricos son la
solución para dejar de depender del
combustible y mejor aún si convertimos
los vehículos de combustión actuales a
un costo accesible américa latina hoy
tiene una oportunidad para desarrollar
medianas y pequeñas empresas de
conversión esto mediante el proceso de
convertir los vehículos actuales en
eléctricos
y eso es desarrollo local ya circulan
650 vehículos convertidos a eléctricos
en américa latina y más de 250 solo en
mexico con la ventaja de costar la mitad
de un coche eléctrico de fábrica y con
consumo eléctrico 5 veces menor que la
gasolina no se puede perder tiempo esto
ya tiene 20 años de aplicación en el
primer mundo organización auto libre
dice punto no sé qué quiere decir con
eso bruno y nos escribe desde méjico
parece entonces poco yo tengo aquí un
mensaje en este caso de daniel que sigue
interactuando con nosotros en nuestro
feed de facebook y dice yo los miro para
sentirme más fresco y esto tiene que ver
con la que hablábamos recién de nuestro
invierno ahora mi pequeño siendo
bastante estamos siendo bastante
castigados por el frío y la nieve
en argentina la semana pasada en el
centro del país fue 40 grados durante 4
ó 5 días seguidos
el grado exacto y en buenos aires las
temperaturas son altísimas yo hablaba
con tengo mi familia en san luís y en
san juan y es brutal el calor y no
afloja ese es el tema se es todo el día
así y gran parte de la noche también o
sea no hay forma de lograr entonces
nosotros nos mandamos con mi familia yo
les mando fotos de mi patio de nieve y
ellos me mandan del patio de dos vago en
realidad de lapiceros que se han
derretido dentro de los autos por el
calor tan derretir tantos deforme así
que realmente es bastante complejo
porque bueno es algo que nos pega a
todos en el norte con mucho frío en el
sur en este caso con mucho calor y es el
cambio climático aunque me sigue
el quincho volador no quiera saber diga
que no que no tiene nada que ver con el
cambio climático méxico está haciendo
mucho frío parece que estuvo haciendo
mucho frío este invierno el día está el
frío de el niño la niña quien está por
ahí cualquiera de los dueños nietos
entonces yo tengo acá un correo un
correo un comentario que nos envía en
frame penya pineda sobre el tema son los
empleos más buscados por las empresas
canadienses y efraín dice excelente
labor del foro 2020
me gusta la información suministrada
ayuda mucho a los inmigrantes como a los
empresarios comentarios de efraín peña
pineda tengo un nuevo cortito aquí de
susana ochoa vega sobre el tema sumiller
y catadora de vinos
andrew lord dice no susana
esa era parte del título
andrew lo dice voy a esperar sus libros
cuándo y dónde es la pregunta a bueno
entonces pues habrá que preguntarle
directamente a susana porque ella
efectivamente pues creo que está por
publicar otro libro para enseñar el
español con una métodos una metodología
digo que le es propia están escuchando
que nada en las américas es que hace el
programa de fin de semana en radio
canadá internacional difundido en
internet en directo por las redes
sociales y también en estos sitios en la
versión radio vamos a pasar ahora a los
temas de la semana que hemos escogido
para todo ese estado
bien no pierda la película prueba
también avisó también alias maría arias
marías me imagino que no es la maria de
josé y la maría tampoco de jorge isaacs
pero ese es el nombre de una chica es
una ficción pero que aborde el tema de
los niños soldados en durante el
conflicto en colombia entonces pues que
como reclutaban los grupos armados a
niños en los diferentes las diferentes
veredas localidades en las zonas de
conflicto y la historia de maría
no la voy a contar todas pues para que
los que vayan a ver la película a
guardarle la sorpresa pero es una niña
soldado de 15 años que
fue reclutada y a la cual se le
encomienda una misión
ella está en una columna en un
campamento si tú quieres de las fuerzas
armadas revolucionarias de colombia y el
comandante de ese de esa columna le da
una misión y es que lleve un a su bebé
el comandante tuvo un con una con otra
guerrillera tuvo una niña y en la misión
de maría es justamente de salvar al bebé
porque él ya tienen ya tienen noticias
qué
ejército la aviación colombiana
identificó el lugar donde ellos se
encuentran y se disponen a bombardear
los y atacarlos y entonces el comandante
el comandante del batallón le encomienda
mariah a que lleve a ese alba a su bebé
a un pueblo vecino para salvarle la vida
entonces esa es la misión es la trama de
la película amarilla está acompañada por
otros tres guerrilleros en esta misión
entre ellos un niño también de 13 años
que los acompaña entonces toda esta
mirada sobre la obligación o sobre el
trabajo que los niños tienen que hacer
que en tanto que guerrilleros y la
responsabilidad que pesa sobre sus
hombros no entonces es interesante es
una película del cineasta colombiano
josé luis rúgeles quien con esta misma
película obtuvo una mención en el
festival de cannes
hace un año en la sección agrega
[Música]
en este momento pasando aquí encontré
esa es la razón por la cual estuve
conversando con josé luís porque está en
cartelera en este momento aquí en
montreal en dos teatros en
[Música]
cinema en el cartel aten y en
o bien ésta se está presentando y se
está presentando también en la ciudad de
québec está en cartelera como hasta a
mediados del mes de febrero hay que
decir que varios de están batallando o
resfríos
la película solo para concluir lo que
sucede también es que finalmente
aceptando esta misión maría está
aceptando de salvarle la vida al bebé
pero finalmente también está tratando de
salvar sus propias heces por el resto lo
dejo a que miren alias maría excelente
película del colombiano josé luis
rúgeles
y canadá tienen historias inmigrantes
exactamente es una exposición virtual
del museo
ward de toronto es un reportaje que yo
hice hace un tiempo ya pero que me pero
sigue sigue válido porque la exposición
es virtual entonces la gente puede ir a
descubrir la historia de estos tres
barrios como sobre medio
ward wv a rd y es que en los barrios de
condenas aquí en montreal de saint
john's perdón de saint john's wards y en
toronto y extractora en vancouver son
tres barrios que se crearon y fueron
florecieron en realidad a partir de las
diferentes oleadas de inmigración que
fueron llegando ahí algunos de ellos de
hecho el de vancouver y el de toronto ya
son más barrios que han adquirido otras
otros usos ya hay menos gente hay más
industrias que se han instalado allí
comercios también pero parece por
ejemplo
el barrio con the night de montreal lo
sabemos está lleno de todos los orígenes
parte económicos y super mi barrio mis
mil barrios primer barrio a quien monte
lo que fue el primer barrio de mucha
gente porque justamente de muchos
quiero decir porque muchos nos vamos
instalando ahí porque son tenemos alguna
red algún conocido que está por ahí y
siguen siendo y sigue siendo un barrio
rico en colores y en sabores y en
idiomas y en culturas entonces esta
exposición virtual en el museo de ward
en toronto pues quiere poner de
manifiesto todos estos esas historias
entonces se sirvieron del trabajo hecho
por académicos por contadores de
historias por artistas para ilustrar
digamos la riqueza de esos 3 barrios en
canadá entonces es un viaje bonito ese
reportaje está en nuestro sitio en
internet
eres 6000 puntos o sea y tú leonard has
estado fíjate en los lentes de la
policía china así es porque me pareció
súper interesante porque justamente en
china que no tienen mucha privacidad que
digamos han llegado al límite de
presentar y fue esta semana un prototipo
de unas lentes de sol que usa la policía
conectados a una base de datos muy
particular porque en realidad la llevan
ellos
y su equipo de su equipo portátil
con reconocimiento facial y han logrado
reconocer a
seis o siete personas que estaban
prófugos de la justicia
con casos bastante complejos y otras 26
27 personas con documentación falsa
solamente
esta gente estos agentes de policía
estaban en una parada ferroviaria
bastante concurrida y andan caminando y
mirando a gente y bueno cuando salta
está esta información los aprenden y
están ellos arrestan en el momento y en
realidad la historia es que están
tratando de cambiar porque hasta ahora
el reconocimiento facial como lo vemos
en las películas no por las cámaras de
seguridad es bastante bastante
deficiente porque las cámaras de
seguridad que están en este tipo de
edificios no son de buena calidad
entonces el proyecto chino es esto es un
proyecto piloto para poder justificar el
cambio de todas las cámaras de seguridad
en todos los lugares públicos en china
para en algún momento y este es el
proyecto lograr detectar y poder tener
un digamos un
un vistazo general de la persona a la
que está mirando con aproximadamente 3
segundos 4 segundos o sea 1 mira en
cuatro segundos tengo todo tu
información en la mano para saber y no
solamente de la persona en este caso lo
que es tejido por la base de datos no
está en la nube es el portátil y
entonces se restringió a diez mil
personas que están en las más exacto las
más buscadas y funciona y funciona y la
gente está como en realidad muy contento
a los chinos
el gobierno chino por la posibilidad de
seguimiento de estas personas y muy
descontentos de todos los ciudadanos y
la gente que está en grupos que cuidan
justamente
digamos a las personas como la
privacidad la persona porque
efectivamente es o sea uno va caminando
por la que hace listo adentro
y se acaban los límites de lo privado en
china exactamente me hace pensar en este
episodio de la serie black mirror se
acuerdan bueno todos tienen una esta
implantación red de la globulina eso y
entonces va reconociendo a la gente y
les das puntos y los dos calificas pero
en este caso es utilizado para
justamente el artículo donde lo sacó de
varios artículos que hablan sobre el
tema hacen referencia a hablar ahora por
este sistema de puntuación pero lo
delicado es que no hay posibilidad de
escaparse porque
mostraban un testeo de este nuevo
sistema y es realmente rápido y bueno yo
vengo caminando con gafas lo veo a rojo
el médano la información de rojos y
trucos está la base de datos también
claro y bueno y es un problema para ese
tipo de costo por una película que todo
el mundo quiera - entonces todos estos
reportajes amigos en nuestro sitio de
internet
heresi net punto sea y el mío lo que lo
recomiendo esta semana es una entrevista
que hice con un veterano de la de la
literatura en crear a jorge echeverri
quien vive el notaba y él fue que yo sé
pues uno de los pocos canadienses latino
que dices que sí conoció a nicanor parra
el poeta chileno que falleció hace el 23
de enero a los 103 años fue una
larguísima vida hermano de violeta parra
una gran gran artista también entonces
con él comenzaba justamente para saber
qué pasaba con nicanor parra y canadá
asia y si se hace parte de la de la
herencia cultural y él decía justamente
que mi canal para llegar a las maletas
del exilio pero que en los hechos nadie
no hay no hay voces que hayan seguido la
forma de escribir sigue que es la
antipoesía de que implica mucho humor y
él decía por qué
los inmigrantes aquí están demasiado
ocupados en sobrevivir como para
ocuparse del humor así que esa fue la
entrevista con eso es lo que yo siempre
he dicho sí sí tiene mucha lo que en
méxico sería casi ya se parece un poco
al albur aunque el amor tiene más una
vertiente picaresca sexual lo que hace
la antipoesía es justamente tomar cosas
cotidianas a hacer para ser pues más de
conos calcetines viejos una cosa sin
síntomas y gracias claro y menos la
gripe
por supuesto que tenemos dos comentarios
más daniel campo línea haciendo
referencia al calor dice buenos aires es
un horno literalmente y javier gonzález
nunca dice hablando del libro leonardo
he menos dijo el programa anterior que
está escribiendo uno
allá
lo dice probablemente lo ha dicho pero
al día me licencié loncán a su intención
porque le implantaría haber sido dotado
con esa hermosísima tarea que es
escribir que ruffo la tiene dicho sea de
paso yo lamentablemente no escrito lo
único que escribo alguna vez con una
noticia o crónica pero
uy quería hablar de una crónica de un
libro ojalá ojalá no realmente no me han
regalado la pluma como como como don me
hubiera gustado mucho escribir pero no
tengo ese don tengo el don de hablar un
poco y decir burradas tengo mucho don
se haría muchísimo dinero si se hiciera
la comedia porque ambos son como dice
antigua película dinamita si podríamos
hacer una comedia y hablando de chistes
justamente ahorita cuando hablábamos de
los chinos me hacía pensar en un chiste
políticamente correcto
excelente para identificar a las
personas porque con más de mil millones
y 2.200 millones de chinos imagínate
poder identificar las personas es un
trabajo enorme y me hacía pensar en un
chiste que contaba un amigo mío que
quizás nos esté escuchando no sé si está
por ahí williams y entonces él decía que
había un chino que venía de una acera y
el otro que iba en el sentido contrario
y se encuentran y se quedan mirando
ambos y dice igualito
entonces ese es el problema que yo creo
así que puede tener
políticamente correcto en la medida en
que como hace a esa tecnología para
poder identificar a las personas que
somos exactamente iguales unos unos a
otros para los chinos si para nosotros
son iguales o sea realmente tienen un
igual yo en una ciudad tan cosmopolita
como no somos todos iguales yo he
aprendido a reconocer a reconocer
japoneses chinos
si a mí me leen nadie está muy nervioso
los oyen los filipinos que sé que tengo
un compañero de voley que filipino y se
llama ramón ibáñez
cuando ramón ibáñez dije habla español
00 de español pero te lo recuerdo de la
ocupación tenemos justamente
un mensaje más por bueno desaparecen en
canadá la cadena de tiendas si has jorge
juárez dice se auto quiebran me recuerda
la crisis de 2008 los accionistas de las
inmobiliarias y los bancos con sus
multimillonarios bonos para después
quebrar sus negocios ellos ganan pues se
recuperan grandes cantidades de dinero y
sus trabajadores en quiebra con sus
pensiones y más aún cuando tienen un
déficit es decir que los platos rotos
los paga el trabajador todo es parte del
mismo teatro la quiebra es parte del
negocio lamentablemente acá en méxico es
bien conocido no cantamos mal las
rancheras esos y apadrinados los fraudes
por los sindicatos y las instituciones
gubernamentales
porque yo tengo los pequeños en el fit
de nuestra página de facebook donde sale
el vídeo bartolina acá niza dice saludos
de toronto que bueno oírte rufo con toda
la información y los compañeros de
equipo y te oyen bien a pesar de que el
otro pequeño mensaje es recuperando
sonrisa es un programa de dentistas
canadienses para mujeres marginales lady
paula vázquez dice hola buenas tardes
soy una mujer de 33 años colombiana
madre cabeza de familia trabajo pero mis
recursos no me alcanzan como para pagar
una odontológica y eso ha acarreado
muchos problemas ya casi no tengo
dientes además de eso empezaron a
aparecer otros problemas y afectar mis
oídos y constantes dolores de cabeza me
gustaría saber si me pueden ayudar
gracias no nosotros desde aquí no
podemos ayudarte pero seguro que en
colombia hay algún plan similar del que
se está llevando a cabo en toronto el
último mensaje el último mensaje con
respecto al reportaje trabajar en turnos
de noche envejece más rápido el cerebro
y pregunta david porque envejecemos más
más rápido de noche trabajando para para
no envejecer qué medicamento puedo
consumir la almohada
sino para vivir evidentemente compleja
bueno en el reportaje supongo que habrá
algunas algunas acciones relacionadas
con este tema y tiene que ver con el
siglo circadiano del plano que indica
que cuando no hay luz el cuerpo se
predispone para dormir si uno lo hace a
trabajar ahí lo fuerza doblemente según
lo que sea bueno amigos con esos con
esos mensajes vuestros gracias por
enviarnos love aquí llegamos al final
del programa estuvieron hoy con ustedes
paloma martínez pablo gómez barrio que
leonardo gimeno
bueno muchos saludos a los espías más
sanos y pues estaremos de regreso la
próxima semana esta vez estará a la
animación la coordinación y estará pablo
así
muy bien